hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow Wildcat video if you didn't
see they just cast jr. Ramirez as Ted
grant that's Wildcats name in real life
so I'm gonna explain his comic book
origins as well as how that show might
change it just a little bit he hasn't
been in the comics recently but he was a
huge part of Justice Society and there's
a whole bunch of other stuff that just
happened in the DC Universe too they
just cast Manhunter not marching
Manhunter the mark sha Manhunter they
announced nine new DC movies after a
Batman vs Superman and I've got to name
a winner in my Comic Con giveaway my
arrow Comic Con giveaway so I'll do all
that stuff
after Wildcat if you're just finding me
for the first time I do arrow and flash
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything so Ted grant origin
story let's go traveling back in time he
debuted in 1942 as a professional boxer
he grew up super poor but his father
taught him to be an animal of sorts in
the ring but in order to earn extra
money to live he had to get a job on the
loading docks one night he saw someone
getting ambushed he beat the out of
the attackers and the person that he
saved turned out to be a retired
prizefighter thus began his pro boxing
career that person that he se backed him
for the heavyweight title that's where
his name Wildcat came from he was just
such an animal in the ring he was really
big really fast and really tough
eventually a local mobster fixed one of
his matches then framed him for it after
he cleared his name he took up the name
Wildcat full time as a superhero alias
and started fighting crime so he got
really inspired by the original Green
Lantern Alan Scott and took up
crime-fighting he was a minor member of
the Justice Society for a while and
later issues the comic like later
whenever Geoff Johns took over they
changed his backstory
he does have some strange mystical
powers the Dark Lord mordioux said that
Wildcat has nine lives like he can die
and come back nine times and as long as
all those deaths don't happen too close
together the lives will refresh and
he'll always have nine lives
so I totally don't think that arrow is
gonna do that I think they're just gonna
make him really tough they're gonna make
him like as tough as a mirakuru soldier
Geoff Johns made him one of the central
Justice Society characters whenever he
started writing the comic back in the
early 2000s that was actually one of his
first big comic runs it was before he
brought back Barry Allen and flash
rebirth so you can think of JSA as being
like a Geoff Johns origin story at least
the origins of his work at these
comics so whenever they changed the Ted
grant backstory during that comic run
they just made him a retired
prizefighter that trained like all the
big Justice Society and Justice League a
listers he did have a son that he never
knew about that showed up his name was
Tommy Bronson and in a twist on the
Wildcat legacy the son ended up being a
ware cat so he could transform into like
a full-on cat that was doing a whole big
Vandal Savage storyline so if you want
to read it it's a really awesome it's
all Jeff John's stuff jr. Ramirez the
actor that they cast looks about old
enough to be a retired pro boxer so they
might go with a modified origin story
for the TV show they posted pictures
from the set of Oliver in a boxing rings
so either Oliver's gonna meet him during
his final fight or he's already gonna be
a retired boxer just working at that
boxing ring either way I think the most
exciting tease is that Oliver is gonna
get some more fighting skills from
Wildcat I mean that's Wildcats biggest
thing being the guy who taught all the
big superheros how to fight or at least
the ones that weren't aliens Superman
does not need to be a nimble fighter
he's indestructible and ES SuperSpeed he
just has to blow really hard and people
will go down there was a really fun
Batman vs Wildcat storyline that you
guys should totally check out - I think
arrows gonna age him down just a little
bit in the comics he comes off as a
little bit of an old man or at least he
thinks of himself as being way past his
prime his JSA team was Alan Scott Jay
Garrick a lot of the classic Golden Age
heroes so whenever Geoff Johns took over
the comic part of the plot was them
reforming the team like they had been
retired for a while it was all in the
post Infinite Crisis stuff if any of you
guys read that storyline if you guys
remember Hawkman was another big Justice
Society character Michael Shanks from
Stargate played him on Smallville but
there are a whole bunch of other
characters Erik could tease this season
and then bring on in the future
like other Justice Society characters
dr. fate was another big team member of
Wildcats they teased him in the
Constantine pilot like you just saw the
helmet of fate but Smallville also did
their version of the character whenever
they did they're just a society arc most
of the supers that come on arrow don't
really stick around I know black
Canary's back for three episodes but
after that she's gone again to make room
for the Ray Palmer Adam and katana but
if you really want to see some other
junior Ramirez stuff you should watch
the Stars show it's called power that's
mostly about a drug lord trying to go
legit so I guess there's some loose ties
with the origins of the original Wildcat
the producers did
the tech rent character would be
spending most of his time on the show
with Laurel since she's working with the
DA it's probably going to have something
to do with organized crime so he might
just end up helping her try to take down
a mob boss and then run into aro while
he's out doing that and they might end
up working together it sounds like he's
not gonna be as close with team arrow as
say Ray Palmer is gonna be but if you
remember during the season 2 finale
there were like a bunch of different
groups of people doing different things
like Quentin and Laurel with the police
Caity Lotz jumping from area to area
with the League of Assassins and Roy was
with Thea till she split and then some
of them met up at the end for that big
street fight in the tunnel so we could
go most of the season without Wildcat
being on Team arrow
they haven't even said which episode
he's gonna debut in but it's definitely
gonna be the first half of the season
when we start thinking about how team
arrow is growing there was this weird
line last season that I keep thinking
about Oliver talked about just getting
back to the core team like the Holy
Trinity but now we have Roy and he's in
this full costume and he's like in
full-on sidekick mode so I think we're
gonna see a couple extra people join the
team in the first half of the season no
word on when katana is gonna show up but
Stephen Amell was teasing his costume
someone was asking him if he's gonna get
an upgraded arrow costume and he said
that things would be added to it so he's
still gonna have the leather pants in
the jacket he's probably just gonna get
some more tech you know maybe from Ray
Palmer who's supposed to be a tech
genius so now moving on to other new
characters Manhunter the mark Shaw
Manhunter is coming on the show if
you're not familiar with that character
he was part of the Suicide Squad and
that's probably how arrows gonna use him
he's gonna be part of the Diggle Lyla
Amanda Waller Suicide Squad stuff
happening this year he's just gonna be
featured in those episodes so it's gonna
be a very minor role
they made him sound like a little bit of
a villain like he and Diggle are going
to cross paths so that doesn't sound
like it's gonna be very friendly but now
moving on to those other DC movies they
just announced so what happened was is
Warner Brothers announced dates for nine
additional superhero movies after Batman
vs Superman no names just dates so I'm
gonna do a separate video for what those
might be be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll try and post in the next couple of
days but really it's gonna start with
the easy stuff like man is steel - a new
solo batfleck movie Justice League
sequel and then a sequel to the Batman
vs. Superman movie maybe Wonder Woman if
Justice League does okay you get the
idea the real thing that
want to talk about is like what those
other four or five movies might be
because those are total mysteries now
it's time to crown a winner in the Comic
Con giveaway Congrats Tootie real you
win an Oliver Funko pop figure I'll be
messaging on your channel for details
so moving on big reminders about when
all these shows are starting so first
off flash starts Tuesday October 7th
arrows gonna be the next day on October
8th so if you're International just
check your local listings if you've
watched arrow in the past that's the
same channel that the flash is gonna be
on and iTunes started selling season
passes for arrow season two last year
around September 13th so they'll
probably the same thing this year so you
will be able to buy season passes for
arrow season 3 in the flash but not for
another month or so I'll be posting my
videos as things happen but you can
always watch them later if you don't
watch the episodes right away as a
measure of last resort the CW also
streams episodes a week after they are
on TV so you have to wait like a whole
week behind everyone else but if you
absolutely have to you can watch them
there too and big congratulations cuz
you guys really stepped up I told you
guys I'd post reviews for Constantine
and Gotham if my last arrow video got
like 2,000 likes and you totally did it
I think it got like three or four
thousand likes so I'll be posting those
videos in the next week so what I'm
gonna do is post the Constantine review
first and then I'll post the Gotham
review so don't worry they'll be big
spoiler warnings but right now click
here to learn all about ratio Google
coming to arrow yes I know it's crazy
that it's happening and click here to
learn all about Captain cold coming to
the flash thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you